Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my Justice League
Crisis on Infinite Earths Movie Video
DC just announced that they're doing a
movie based on crisis on Infinite Earths.
Which is ironic
because have we been here before?
Didn't we just do Crisis
on Infinite Earths in the DCTV verse?
They were also planning
on doing Crisis on Infinite Earths
in the movies with the live action.
Henry Cavill based Zack Snyder
Universe of DC Characters.
all explained
what those alternate plans are
and what this new crisis
on Infinite Earths movie is going to be.
What it's meant to do.
So if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos,
I know it sounds confusing
because they used to have
all these different plans
and it sounds like they weren't
going to do Crisis on Infinite Earths
in the movies because they're rebooting
into the James
Gunn DCU Universe of Movies.
But this is meant to be.
The end of the tomorrow verse of the DC
animated movies with the R-rated DC movies
that they've been doing
the past couple of years.
this week, as I'm posting this video,
they're getting ready to release
Justice League Warworld they have like
Jensen Ackles, Batman, the Darren Criss
version of Superman
that started in Superman Man of Tomorrow.
Like this line of continuity
that they're calling the Tomorrow
verse of animated movies in it sounds like
they're going to reboot all the DC
animated movies into the James Gunn DCU
where everything becomes canon together.
always played that in a second
because their plan going forward
is for everything to be candid together.
Kind of the same way that the Marvel
animated and TV
shows on Disney
Plus are canon to all the MCU movies now.
whereas before that wasn't the case
before the big James Gunn reboot,
you had all these different lines
of continuity,
like the animated movies
were their own thing.
You had a bunch of standalone
animated movies
that were akin to the other
animated movies.
some of the live action
stuff was taking place
in different continuities,
like the Joaquin Phenix.
Joker was in a different universe
from the Matt Reeves.
Batman was in a different universe
from the Zack Snyder
Snyder verse of Justice League movies.
So as many of you know,
DC has been disconnected
in film and television for a long time.
And it's one of, you know, our jobs,
mine and Peter's is to come in
and make sure the DCU is connected
in film,
television, gaming and animation,
that the characters are consistent,
played by the same actors,
and it works within one story.
And if something is outside of that,
like Matt Reeves, Batman
or Todd Phillips, Joker or Teen Titans go
that it is clearly labeled
as DC Elseworlds outside of the mainstream
DCU continuity.
James Gunn is slowly sort of uniting
all that with a very few exceptions.
Like we still have
the Matt Reeves Batman universe,
which is going to continue
to do its own thing,
probably through a trilogy,
until they eventually completely
just go to the one version of Batman that
will eventually meet when they do Batman
brave in the Bold
and they probably will not do
another sequel to the Joaquin Phenix Joker
two movies.
So that'll be the end of that line
of continuity as well
to kind of slowing everything up
in the same continuity.
if you weren't at Comic-Con this weekend,
they actually did a special premiere
for Justice League Warworld
their release that
in the next couple of days on home video.
So you be able to watch in a couple
of days, no matter what that's loosely
based on the classic Gladiator,
Superman versus Mongul battle
in the Superman exile storyline
back in the eighties where he briefly left
Earth winds up on Warworld
has to challenge Mongul in gladiator
combat
like he wears the gladiator costume.
Everybody remembers the gladiator costume
that basically involves Mongul beating
the crap out of him, Planet Hulk style
and him having to actually learn
how to fight like a gladiator
in a knockdown, drag out fight
where his power levels
are similar to someone else
that he's fighting.
Because before this,
he never really actually had to fight.
Remember,
this is happening long before the big
death of Superman arc with Doomsday.
So he hasn't fought doomsday yet.
Zack Snyder kind of got into this
phenomenon during the Man of Steel movie
where Superman is so powerful, like he's
basically a God on earth.
He's never actually had to learn
how to fight.
like he just learns to control his power
so he doesn't accidentally kill
a whole bunch of people.
But he never actually learns
to really fight like a military person
will learn how to fight or an actual
fighter.
so. When Zod and the Kryptonian show up,
they wind up kicking his ass
pretty quickly
because they're about the same power level
until he slowly learns to fight
a little bit better
through the course of that movie
in the more reason comics,
like literally just a couple of years ago,
they did a New Superman
Worlds of War Alternate Future series
as part of this event called Future State,
where Superman had a fight on Warworld
and gladiator combat in a similar way
without his powers But it was like
a distant post-apocalyptic future.
And in that timeline,
things got all wonky.
he winds up being captured
and taken to Warworld and Mongul is son
who since taken over the original Mongul
died a long time ago in the comics.
kills Superman
almost every day, then resurrects him.
It just keeps going on until eventually
Superman is able to lead an insurrection
and take over Warworld.
So if you wonder where all the Superman
gladiator costumes come from
and you haven't read the comics,
that's where they came from.
they're a couple jokes
about those costumes
in the more recent comics
with like Lois Lane making him keep it
so they can get super freaky with it,
do a little bit of roleplaying
make all the jokes you want about that.
the been a couple of times in the comics
where the Justice League has been forced
to fight in gladiator combat
like they did a Justice League
animated series version of the war world
story.
Justice
League was forced to fight in gladiator
combat during the Dark Nights
metal series a little while ago.
So the idea is that next year crisis on
Infinite Earths is based on the tomorrow
verse line of continuity with them
loosely adapting the plot of comic book
Crisis on Infinite Earths.
But it will carry forward
the ending of Justice League Warworld
in those main characters it'll probably be
one of the final DC animated movies
that are part of that tomorrow.
Verse Continuity before
James Gunn's reboot of DC movies
takes effect with Creature Commandos.
That's like the first Canon
DC animated series that he's doing.
Meaning.
With the start of that,
all the animated actors
will also play their characters
in live action,
like they've already confirmed
that some of the creature commando
animated characters
will show up in the live action projects
after that in the same will be vice versa,
like the new version of Superman,
the new version of Batman
that's inside this Justice
League universe.
The DCU is James Gunn is calling it
They'll also show up
in the animated projects eventually, too,
but they've only announced one
animated project, this canon so far,
and that's Creature Commandos.
animated movies
take a couple years to complete,
so they already know what the next couple
of animated projects are.
James Gunn
just hasn't announced what they are yet.
but it's kind of the same thing
that Marvel has been doing
since they started doing the Disney
Plus series,
where you have the animated characters
from the what ifs.
There is also playing their characters
in live action like Captain Carter.
Jeffrey Wright is going to come back
as the watcher in live action projects,
most of the live action actors played
the animated versions of their characters.
Not every single one, but most of them
if you remember a couple of years ago,
they kind of did the same thing in the DC
animated movies with Justice League
Dark Apocalypse War, which was another
really cool rated or animated movie.
It was actually really, really good.
it served as the final movie
in the DC animated movie Universe timeline
when they rebooted into the Tomorrow verse
with Superman Man of Tomorrow
in the Darren Criss version of Superman.
so another kind of doing the exact
same thing with the tomorrow verse
timeline,
ending it with Crisis on Infinite Earths.
But because they are going full
crisis, it's a big multiverse movie.
They can bring back all the characters
from all these previous animated movie
universes and the animated TV shows
and bring them into the same continuity.
so like at the end of Justice League
Dark Apocalypse war
the Flash rebooted the timeline again.
People are like, Oh, what happened?
All those characters.
They can actually explain that during
the crisis on Infinite Earths movie.
maybe if we're lucky, we'll also get
a bunch of live action cameos
to Spider-Verse style like Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse and Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse have been mixing
live action and animated elements.
Hopefully they try to do the same thing
with the Crisis on Infinite Earths movie.
I'm not going to hold my breath on that,
but we'll see.
So I'm assuming that they're using
this crisis on infinite Earths
to reboot into the James Gunn DCU,
which will start with creature commandos.
Now there is an animated Watchmen movie
that they just announced.
It's meant to be a totally separate thing.
It's not canon to the DC animated movies
or anything like that, even though
technically they did canonize Watchmen
to the DC Universe a couple of years ago
you could just hear Alan Moore
screaming about that If you don't know.
Alan Moore In real life,
he hated the idea of tying
Watchmen to the larger DC universe.
think of the new animated Watchmen movie,
which will also probably be rated R
as a more faithful adaptation
of the original Watchmen comic book.
Which is kind of funny
because Zack Snyder's Watchmen actually
had animated elements to it
during the Tales of the Black Freighter.
that was meant to be
a fictional in-universe comic book story
meant to be a metaphor for the action
in present day with Doctor Manhattan.
It'd be like someone in a Superman movie
reading a Batman comic book
inside the Superman movie
in the plot of that comic book foreshadows
everything that happens in the reality
of the Superman movie in present day,
Justice League Warworld is rated R,
So I'm assuming Crisis on Infinite Earths
will also be rated R Justice League
Dark APOKOLIPS War was also rated R
really loving that DC is doing all these
R rated animated movies,
or if you live in another country,
it's basically
rated mature,
like whatever the highest rating is.
Usually the reason why they give them that
hardcore rating
is just because of violence.
I've already done a couple videos
about the live action version
of the crisis on Infinite Earths movie
that they had planned on doing before.
James Gunn Big reboot became a thing
That was why they had the black Adam
Superman Post-Credits
scene with the Henry Cavill Superman
the tease him coming back.
Why Henry
Cavill released that special video
about them doing a bunch of stuff like you
will be rewarded for waiting for so long
for me to do my next movie
the idea is that
they were going to use the Flash movie
in a big post-credits scene
that they wind up
deleting where Superman comes back, Wonder
Woman comes back, Ben Affleck's Batman
gets lost to the multiverse and teases
this coming crisis, so to speak.
they were originally going
to end the Flash movie with him
changing the can of tomatoes
to get his father out of prison.
So he makes a minor change.
Michael Keaton in Supergirl
Wind up on the main earth again
with the rest of the regular Justice
League that,
you know, like Henry Cavill, Superman.
Ben Affleck's
Batman gets lost in the multiverse.
With the change in the timeline,
the Barry creates.
And he warns him in a dream
about a coming crisis,
that was meant to be like a ten year plan.
So like, they weren't going to do the next
movie as Crisis on Infinite Earths.
They were going to do a Justice League,
too, with the Snyder verse cast of actors.
But Michael Keaton, Batman replacing
Ben Affleck's Batman temporarily
then eventually
once they do build up to that
live action crisis on infinite Earths,
they bring everybody back in a whole bunch
of better looking versions of cameos
like you saw in The Flash movie,
like the Chrono Boat cameo scenes.
Imagine much, much better versions of that
This time probably actually having Grant
Gustin flash cameos,
cameos from the live action DC TV actors
like they should have had
during the Flash movie
probably
would have been a much better movie
if they would had Grant Gustin
and even like Christian Bale's Batman,
I've already done a much longer video
on all the flash deleted
scenes,
all the Superman Henry Cavill stuff.
They took out all the other deleted scenes
and deleted cameo scenes,
so I'll post a link
in the description below.
But if we hear any more,
we get more trailers for this
Crisis on Infinite Earths movie.
Then I'll do more videos for it.
There were a couple other really big
things that were released at Comic-Con.
I'll try to do videos
for all the trailers,
all the big announcements,
so be sure to enable alerts on my channel
so you don't miss anything.
Click here for that
Invincible Season 2 trailer video.
It looks like it's going to be amazing
and click here for all my other Comic-Con
trailer videos and episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!